en revanche les lèvres ont dégonflé
c'est pas mal combattant les lettres qui
gonfle non non non ça fait presque 50
ans quand vous laissez vous non non non
c'est naturel parce que laurent seuil
est avec nous aujourd'hui c'est un
bonheur quelle belle pas me regarder
parce qu'on voulait quelqu'un qui met du
baume au coeur à bernard montiel pour
selon-vous l'anniversaire est ce que
c'est l'anniversaire de bernard monte à
[Musique]
38 ans il a toujours un rôle ou cana
sera totale un tabac oui ça va me
rattrape en tout cas ces châssis sénégal
fait pas un de ses champs de quatre ans
4 un pote tout à l'heure qui m'a dit ça
en vannes
il m'a dit ah oui là bas il a fait ses
64 ans bernard je suis dit non mais tu
rigole pas son vrai qu'il m'a dit arrête
oui je suis je regrette on vous à
wikipédia non mais ça tient mais on a vu
que c'était vrai 6 9 avril 1957 comme
votre ami gad est exactement ces
anniversaires de gad elmaleh eu
également que j'embrasse très très fort
nous gâte
[Applaudissements]
attendent après l'anniversaire de son
amoureux daniel riolo et les divines
il est horrifiant les directs
[Applaudissements]
penser des séquences et plus pourris
l'histoire de cet homme croit c'est sûr
et certain
mais là on en est et ce alors ça y est
c'est vrai que c'est un très beau cadeau
oui j'ai appris alors n'y a pas de
cadeau de votre cadeau ce qu'elles
peuvent fasse pas ses missions avec vous
c'est pas faux nous fait plaisir on peut
pas remporter quoi vous n'avez non non
non olala mais quelle lourde
ils ont même un coût légèrement tel est
brillant style de femme elle est très
sexy
tamer toi c'est ce que bernard montiel
ce raid est votre costume d'homme tout à
fait non c'est pas vrai la réponse est
oui tout de suite mais alors si les
palais de la série non pas parce qu'en
sait on s'appelle on se parle
nous avons un contact attention cette
agression laurent tillie va t on pas oui
joker non non je le dis oui non moi je
sais vous vous êtes célibataire
ouais oh là là là là là et c'est pas mal
hein tu as peu match aller 2 1
vous savez quoi oui savez quoi en plus à
l'époque a été porte parole des élèves
il avait déjà parlé des j'avais remarqué
non je dis cette fille est
l'extraordinaire en avait parlé en très
haut lieu d'ailleurs et j'avais dît si
seulement
on n'a pas la farouk ton chien je disais
femmes et priante belle
c'est quelqu'un comme ça qu'il faudrait
voilà non non si 6e
laurence est ce que vous la réciproque
est ce qu'elle en a parlé à un haut lieu
est ce que vous l'avez par le haut lieu
c'est à dire parce que vous avez vous
précisiez là qu'est ce que vous aviez
remarqué bernard montiel mais en vidéo
via un chat qui va leur exemple c'est un
bon début allez on va tout jouer contre
mes toby tommy ou des morts qui anime
les problèmes gastriques qu'on lui verse
adam vidéo gac est plus complexe de
leurs engrais k comme ça oui et jean
royer j'en rêvais mais grâce à vous on a
été réunie quoi vous rendre sur un
bateau non s'entend bien par contre vous
excuse moi vous avez acheté un cabriolet
[Rires]